hey everybody its propaganda time Donald
Trump is about to tell us how we are the
best at everything but in particular
testing welcome it's been a little while
since the last stream feels like a long
time it's only been a few days though
and indeed today we have a press
briefing during which Donald Trump is
going to make an important statement
about testing you can see what the
statements going to be America leads the
world in testing of course the truth as
you all know is that the u.s. does not
lead the world in testing as you can see
in tests per capita you've got to scroll
down and down and down and down and then
you eventually find the United States
here
so it's going to be a lot of propaganda
I hope people are ready for it because
it's going to be absolutely brutal it's
gonna be an absolutely brutal amount of
propaganda and lies today but we will do
the best we can to deal with it together
I think is what we would say what's
going on I
oh I am on antibiotics that cut that
happened because of an extremely alpha
thing I did last week it got infected I
did everything right I kept it clean I
was cleaning it I cleaned it right away
with hydrogen peroxide antibiotic cream
and putting band-aids on and I think it
was because of my incredibly masculine
gardening over the weekend it's possible
that some potting soil may have gotten
in there I don't know elements of
vegetables possibly and it did get
infected it did get infected and it was
quite quite deep so I am on antibiotics
about halfway through okay so far you
know nothing nothing big to report but
dramatically dramatically reduced signs
of infection so I think that that's
that's the good news that's the good
news
super chats are already coming in great
to see everybody make it simple says
please add more emotes on Twitch I don't
know how to do that but I I mean if
there's no opportunity cost to doing it
I gladly would assess the African says
your biggest gripe with the Republican
Party they live in a fantasy world then
everything stems from that fantasy world
they live in
unknown prodigy says David if Ally is in
big print it must be true
yeah Trump tweeting a lot of all cap
stuff and Jacob Ratner says Obama gate
was trending all day yesterday after
Trump's tweet have you ever seen such
major projection yeah they're no longer
operating in reality and in fact the
world is laughing at Donald Trump I have
a bunch of articles here let me see here
this is an article from where is this
from I don't remember where this is from
what what language is this is this uh
I'm not sure what this is
anyway I been collecting a bunch of
articles as you can see here
disinfectant clearly is referring to the
infamous bleach injection fiasco so many
countries this is from South Africa
Trump suggests trying UV light injected
disinfectant as a possible cure this is
from Peru this is the the facial
expression on the health person for
Trump after his suggestion that
disinfectant be injected to treat corona
virus pointing out dr. Burks I mean it's
really bad whoops that's that's for
later I don't want to go to that yet so
the world is laughing and yet Donald
Trump is going to continue claiming
today that we are the best and everybody
is looking to us and it's all amazing
and in fact at a recent press briefing
Donald Trump told this and we're going
to do a job like like nobody's seen
before and I spoke with Angela Merkel
today I spoke with Prime Minister Abbey
of Japan I spoke with many of the
leaders over the last four or five days
and so many of them almost all of them I
would say all of them not everybody want
to admit it but they over your says the
world leader yeah that's obviously not
true and if people are looking to the
United States on coronavirus it's
because they want to know what not to do
what not to do because it's been a
disaster
may we Trump now is maybe going to
benefit from the fact that the Brazilian
president jarba Sun ro may have had an
even worse response as the Brazilian
numbers are growing in fact we can take
a look at that real quick
see Brazil here it is and as you can see
here the that's an ugly curve in Brazil
as many of you probably recognize even
worse than the United States where
things are basically flat
we are officially just shy of 1.4
million cases eighty one and a half
million deaths we are seeing
increasingly more and more new cases
proportionally in places like Texas
Texas used to always have a tiny number
of new cases compared to California
Maryland Massachusetts Texas yesterday
with more new cases than those places
Georgia is getting to be a hot spot
Virginia is another one Florida's kind
of holding steady but it's it's not it's
not really looking great is the news I
guess that we need to be discussing okay
welcome if you're watching on Twitter
twitch Facebook or YouTube I very very
much appreciate it we are or people
shilling Bitcoin in the chat is that I
see that people are there are people
talking about Bitcoin that's interesting
I mean listen I I have not been shilling
for Bitcoin but I made clear that I've
been slowly accumulating a little more
of it over the last two months and it's
it's way way up so I can't say I'm
displeased by having done that that's
that's for sure let's see here Alex
a drum twit ler has subscribed on
YouTube Alex Stephenson says via super
chat feel free to get in touch via super
chat are you still growing out your hair
any hopes of a man bun in the near
future yeah I mean I've not gotten a
haircut it's you can't tell how long it
is only because it's just so heavy now
that it's flopping over but it's
actually it's look at this I mean some
of this this could be ten inches of hair
you can't really tell but yeah it's it's
still growing out and no signs anytime
soon that that's gonna change because
there's no haircuts happening and it's
close I could soon it's I could actually
put a rubber band around it it's
actually crazy if we get to 50 members
today I will actually have a ponytail on
tomorrow
stream that it is possible physically
and I will commit to doing that and we
will see we'll see how that goes but
yeah that I would consider doing that
only under the right situations okay
Keith stone says how can Democrats
prepare now for a possible Trump
reelection listen guys what we can
remove that we can remove him in
November so let's let's prepare to win
and then we'll deal with re-election if
it happens dragon mum less living
entropy has subscribed on YouTube
Juggalo tray says hey David Pakman I am
pretty dumb but can you explain the
process of absentee voting yes you get a
ballot in the mail you fill it out and
you send it in that's the process in
some states you have to request a ballot
California has decided they are going to
send everyone a ballot every registered
voter will automatically get a ballot
which is which is fantastic it's
fantastic Mart Fillion says hey David I
did I do not know if you have figured
out a way for people to send gift
memberships but what about social
financing I don't know what you mean by
social financing the best way the
easiest way to gift memberships is
actually on twitch twitch twitch has a
great system for doing it on our website
we've not yet turned the corner so to
speak on on that but that's on the list
of possible elements for the website
redesign before we get started here real
quick I do want to remind people that
Donald Trump's current press secretary
once said that he was a hateful racist
remember this how sick of polls are
people in New Hampshire right now
probably very sick especially when they
see that Donald Trump is number two and
doesn't deserve to be there the GOP
doesn't need to be turning away voters
and isolating them we need to be
bringing them into the tent Donald Trump
is the last person who's going to do
that Haley this is your guy he's number
two in the polls hey I don't want to
claim this guy the fact that the
Republican Party is now having to claim
and it's both unfortunate and to me
inauthentic what's the expiration date
then on a racist statement to me a
racist statements a racist statement I
don't like what Donald Trump said I do
anyway so there it is she explained it
away to recent press briefing like this
president
some Mexican immigrants are rapists and
criminals you said that that language
was racist and hateful do you notice she
has a page for this that she's turning
to I'm actually glad you asked that
because first four weeks of the election
I was watching CNN and I was naively
believing some of the headlines and they
imagine she says when I mistakenly said
Trump was racist it was because CNN
tricked me hire this woman on CNN not
going to read the headline so I very
quickly took came around supported the
president in fact CNN hired me I was a
mini 8 wait a second so you went to work
for a place that you said was riddled
with fake news that's weird one panels
where I proudly supported this president
who I believe is one of the best
presidents it's not the best president
this country will ever have but I would
encourage the individual who did that
analysis of my past rather than focusing
on me he really should be focused on
some of the very guests CNN chose tab
right so now she simply goes into
criticizing CNN so this is a ridiculous
explanation she's essentially saying
when I thought bad things about Trump it
was because I was duped by fake news CNN
of course if you are so easily duped by
fake news CNN it doesn't sound like
you're competent enough to be press
secretary and also why did you accept a
position with them if they are so
problematic I mean it's just a joke it's
a joke and she had that ready in her in
her book of media attack so it's it's
just sick it's very very sick okay let's
see here super chats continue to come in
Samuel Lopez says 'bonus started this
that meet likewise thank you Tom Oh
Wayne says us are a laughing stock to
the world even in the UK oh here's Trump
coming in I will I see the new member
thank you the new members coming in I
will thank people afterwards but let's
listen for the time being
that's weird we've got no audio there
let's try maybe a different stream here
the Whitehouse stream hasn't started yet
that's odd why did we get no audio it's
certainly not muted but I am Not sure
that is really weird don't work we're
gonna get it all guys don't worry but I
am just trying to see what is going on
here very weird cuz all of our other
tabs were working let's go to this one
there we go
we're here today to provide an update on
the unprecedented testing capacity
developed by the United States why the
most advanced and robust testing system
anywhere in the world by fly this
afternoon I'll also announced new steps
that we're taking to make tests even
more widely available to battle a virus
my administration marshaled every
resource at our nation's disposal public
private military economic scientific and
industrial all at your disposal right we
launched the largest manufacturing
ramped up since the Second World War
there's been nothing like it since at
the center of this industrial and
scientific mobilization was the
development of our corona virus testing
capabilities in the span of just a few
short months we've developed a testing
capacity unmatched and unrivaled
anywhere in the world and it's not even
close accepted by 40 other states that
do more testing per capita actually
reopen America and we're opening and
we're starting and there's enthusiasm
like I haven't seen in a long time every
American should be proud of the amazing
array of talent skill and enterprise our
nation is brought to this challenge in
three months the FDA has authorized more
than 92 different tests and over nine
million have been performed here in the
United States three weeks ago we were
conducting roughly 150,000 tests per day
now we're doing approximately 300
thousand tests per day
a 100% increase
and that is true over the last four days
and it's still about half of where we
need to be it's well past ten million
tests conducted nearly double the number
of any other country we're testing more
people per capita than South Korea the
United Kingdom France Japan Sweden
Finland Finland and many other countries
we are still 41st though combined on
Friday the FDA authorized coronavirus
antigen test and alternative testing
technology that can be much more readily
manufactured cui Dell Corporation which
makes this newly authorized point of
care test estimates that it will be able
to manufacture one hundred and fifty
thousand tests per day immediately
increasing to three hundred thousand
tests per day within just a few weeks to
further expand our nation's testing
capabilities this afternoon I am
announcing that my administration is in
and we've got this all approved it's all
done which is sending 1 billion dollars
to America's States territories and
tribes so this has all been approved
we've gotten it done completed the money
is going out this major investment will
ensure that America continues to conduct
more tests than any country on earth by
far I said from the beginning that the
federal government would back up the
states and help them build their testing
capability and capacities and that's
exactly what's happened this partnership
has truly flourished we have really had
a very good relationship with the states
and the governors and other
representatives within the States
a relationship like I think I can
honestly say has not been seen in this
country for many many years the
governors and us are working together
very closely not only in testing but on
ventilators where we have a capacity
that's at this point virtually unlimited
and we're sending ventilators as you
probably heard from other countries
we're sending many many thousands of
ventilators to other countries because
they're in tremendous need and I think
building up a lot of goodwill but much
more importantly than that we're saving
a lot of lives
most states are now doing
great job my administration located
5,000 machines and 700 labs across all
50 states and governors have learned how
to maximize these testing resources the
federal government is also supporting
states with vital supplies quick
approvals of new tests and one-on-one
coaching from the team here at the White
House on how to increase capacity and
increase it very quickly in recent weeks
we've held multiple conference calls
with every state as well as with DC and
Puerto Rico we jointly develop testing
projections and goals for each state for
the month of May all together totaling
twelve point nine million tests think of
that twelve point nine million - if we
can do that we would be at about 80
percent of the absolute minimum where we
need to be if if if that's done so their
goal is still 20% short of the minimum
we were supposed to be at a month ago
delivering twelve point nine million
swabs to States nationwide we already
have them the delivery will be very
quick we're prepared to provide millions
of additional swabs if any state is on a
pace to surpass its goal and their goals
are very high we've set them very high
we've told them to set them very high my
administration will also provide
approximately nine million transport
media which are used to transfer swabs
to the lab processing a complicated
process but we've made it simple as a
result of these actions every single
state will be able to test more people
per capita in May alone then South Korea
has tested in four months since the
outbreak began the South Korea has fixed
the problem so their need for testing at
this point now all of a sudden Trump
only wants to talk about South Korea
South Korea doesn't have 2,000 deaths a
day absent thermo Fisher some of these
incredible companies produced sand
produced rapidly for us and their
products are here with us this afternoon
these are all different products that
were literally just developed exciting
product if you can imagine that is the
best of machines and the best equipment
anywhere in the world and other
countries are calling us and we're
trying to work as much as we can not
only unventilated
but also with testing my administration
also continues our tireless effort to
expand testing in the most underserved
communities through our partnership with
the private sector leading pharmacies
and retailers are now operating over 240
testing sites across the country and
that's in addition to all of the other
sites that we have working 70% of these
sites are located in communities with
unique vulnerabilities there will be
more than 300 sites by the end of this
week and retailers are making plans to
open up hundreds and hundreds more
locations within the next 30 days these
additional sites are helping us since
your access to testing and every
community my administration is fighting
relentlessly to protect all citizens of
every color and Creed from this terrible
virus the invisible enemy in addition to
vast amounts of testing supplies my
administration is partnered with the
private sector to coordinate the
delivery of more than 90 million n95
masks and these are of the highest
quality many are made right here in the
United States at capacity we didn't have
it all at the beginning 126 million
surgical masks likewise many are made
here nine million face shields 21
million surgical gowns nine hundred
ninety three million gloves and ten
thousand six hundred and ninty
ventilators who are building thousands
of ventilators in numerous plants all
across our country it's incredible this
would all be pretty good if it was seven
weeks ago right so like now we're
finally starting to do some of the
things which would have made sense to do
when South Korea was doing them course
we mourn for every life the virus has
claimed and we share the grief of all of
the you who've lost a loved one and that
goes worldwide to many many countries
184 countries at least thanks to the
courage of our citizens and our
aggressive strategy hundreds of
thousands of lives have been saved and
we have saved and if you look at on a
per 100,000 basis we're at the best part
of the pack
right on the bottom Germany and us are
leading the world German radically 14th
highest in deaths per capita 14th
highest in deaths per capita patient
through every challenge and hardship and
danger America is risen to the task we
have met the moment and we have
prevailed Americans do whatever it takes
to find solutions pioneer breakthroughs
and harness the energies we need to
achieve a total victory day after day we
are making tremendous strides with the
dedication of our doctors and nurses
these are incredible people these are
brave people these are warriors with the
devotion of our manufacturing workers
food suppliers and lab technicians and
with the profound patriotism of the
American people we will defeat this
horrible enemy we will revive our
economy and we will transition into
greatness that's a phrase you're gonna
hear a lot because that's what's going
to happen yeah from you going into the
third quarter and we're gonna do well in
the fourth quarter we're gonna do very
good and next year I think we're gonna
have one of the best years we've ever
had because there's a tremendous pent-up
demand hopefully he'll be going it's a
demand and I'm feeling it I've felt
things a lot over my life and a lot a
lot of good calls it's a demand like I
don't think I've ever seen there's a
pent-up demand as a there's a spirit in
this country like few have seen and I
think you can say and we've helped a lot
of the countries a lot more there's a
tremendous spirit all over the world to
beat this terrible terrible thing but
we're transitioning to greatness and the
greatness is going to be in the fourth
quarter but it's really going to be next
year and it's gonna be a year like we've
never had before I really believe that
as we've done and we've done great we
had the best economy in the history of
the world not just here but anywhere in
the world you can talk Jana you can talk
any other country we had the best
economy anywhere in the world and we
were going for numbers weather was
unemployment numbers well we had our
best numbers employment also numbers
little
where we had our best numbers at almost
a hundred and sixty million people all
of that we had the greatest stock market
numbers ever I think we're hundred and
forty two days where we set records in a
short period of time a hundred and fifty
two days we set records in the stock
market we rebuilt our military all built
in the United States all of our
equipment built one point five trillion
dollars plus as the cupboards were bare
on the southern border the wall is being
built it's being built rapidly and now
you don't hear the opponent's talking
too much about the border they don't
like to talk about it because it seemed
that we were right on a lot of things
one of the things we were right about
one of the many things was the border we
have a very powerful border now we had
one of the best weeks in the history of
our border between the United States and
Mexico our southern border we had very
few people coming in very very few
almost record low numbers and the wall
is being built it's up to 181 miles
already it's being built it's being
built rapidly people don't talk about it
anymore because it's very successful in
the area where the wall has built that
is a lot still but we want to be up to
450 by very short period of time early
next year we should be up to 450 and
very shortly after that over 500 miles
to be gone by completed we do our job
but it's had a tremendous impact but
again we've had the best numbers the
last thing we want now with this
pandemic is for people to come across
our southern border and again we're
doing record numbers meaning record low
numbers right so I just want to thank
everybody and I want to introduce
Admiral guar if you could please come up
and bread if you would Brad Smith GW
they're gonna do a little explaining as
to what we've done with regard to
testing and how successful it's been and
then we'll take some questions after
that
thank you very much stunning well thank
you mr. president for your leadership
and for your high expectations that
really made this all come together oh
there's a you needing the speakers now
from
now that the virus is inside the White
House I get it for providing his
leadership at HHS and allowing both Brad
and I the opportunity to work on this
project I think it's clear that America
does lead the world in testing I'll go
through some of the charts this should
lead quantitatively I will also suggest
that we lead in the diversity of tests
which are very important to establish
the testing ecosystem to keep America
safe and clearly as we've said multiple
times no one beats America when it comes
to quality guys I want to start clear
about this Trump's stated goal of 12
million tests in May if we achieve it
would only be 80% of the minimum that we
we were trying to get to a month and a
half ago okay if it goes well we're
still 20% short we'll top over 9 million
tests and if you look at per capita
everyone talks about South Korea being
the standard not anymore today we will
have done more than twice their per
capita rate of testing so I I hate to
keep interrupting but you guys need to
understand South Korea has no cases
anymore they have no one to test there's
no symptoms so I mean it not literally
but South Korea dealt with this six
weeks ago so now continuing to compare
to South Korea
we're 41st and testing per capita South
Korea itself is not really the important
thing now the authorization by the FDA
under the leadership of our secretary of
many different diagnostic tests of
diagnostic devices and now of serology
tests so you've heard a lot about the
different testing and you see some of
the machines up here most of the
diagnostic tests all but one rely on the
amplification of the viral RNA the viral
new kinetic material and we've talked to
you about the diversity of tests they're
very high throughput tests that are done
at big reference labs like LabCorp and
quest but very importantly there are
also tests and you heard us talk about
Cepheid delivering over two vitally
important to rural americas and to
places that do not have very large
infrastructure you've also seen the
Abbott test we've talked about there it
is
on the left of the president delivering
about 1.4 million tests as a
point-of-care test you get the result
within 5 to 15 minutes and we have
deployed over two hundred and
thirty-five thousand of these tests to
the state public health laboratories in
every state of this country to make sure
that that point of care testing
capability is there to research
outbreaks like in nursing homes or in
certain industrial capacities and well
over ninety thousand to the Indian
Health Service so they could test at a
point of care in remote locations the
president also talked about a new first
in-class test it's listed there as an
antigen based test this is very
important and you've heard ambassador
Burke that I think about this multiple
times because antigen testing although
complex is much less complex than the
nucleic acid testing that we've had quit
Dell had this authorized by the FDA and
as the president said we'll soon be
making over three hundred thousand tests
per day do the math that's nine million
point-of-care tests that we will have
every month in just a few weeks it will
clearly add to into a certain degree
transform our landscape which you don't
see up here is the important work the
FDA did I'm a swab guy now I'm very
interested in swabs in order to make all
these tests work you have to show that a
certain swab made of a certain material
performed in a certain way delivers a
highly accurate result and what you're
seeing up here is some of the fruits of
that labor without the authorizations of
for example the foam nasal swab we would
be blowing through PPE all across the
country because of the need for full PPE
just to take a test that has really been
changed by this diverse authorization
and a recent authorization allows the
great manufacturer u.s. cotton to join
our foundational injury industry of
purity I guess I'm a swap guy too while
we're at it
last week we did over 1.9 million tests
and that number is growing and again as
the president said and Brad will talk
about our state's aspired to do well
over 12 million
over the next four weeks you see the
graph growing which you also see very
importantly is that little orange bar on
the bottom is the cumulative number of
positives our percent positives are
going down and that's what we want to
see in fact in 31 States as of last
night the positivity rate is less than
10% which is not a litmus test but is a
good idea that we're doing plenty enough
testing that we can enter phase 1 for
careful reopening I also want to take
the opportunity to say this doesn't
happen by accident
I'm seeing everyone in the audience here
and I'm so pleased that they can be here
people sitting in the front have been
working literally 18 to 20 hours a day
every single day of the week for at
least the past two months none of this
happens by accident it happens because
their hard work their sacrifice their
sacrifice of their family all for a
common good and I'm very very honored to
consider to you all as my colleagues in
my last slide as the president said
eleven billion dollars are now being
announced to be delivered to the States
for the sole support of testing this
will give them the resources to partner
as they have with the federal gun Durst
and this is what should have been done
two months ago
task force with Brad and I we're gonna
be very specific and they know it that
there needs to be minimum numbers to be
planned to test they have to have plans
for their vulnerable communities
including nursing homes including those
who are disabled including those are in
prisons or who have working environments
that they may have a more likelihood to
spread the infection and combined with
that it's the secretary's office of
minorities health will soon be awarding
a large contract to guarantee a national
network of state local and
community-based organization money to
assure that those underserved
particularly racial and ethnic
minorities are linked to the surfaces
they need not only testing but in care
as well and with that I'd like to hand
it over to Brad
Smith who's the director of the Center
for Medicare and Medicaid innovation but
has really been the chief operating
officer to make all of this come
together
Brad Thank You Admiral I want to talk
through a little bit specifically the
work that we've been doing with the
states so as the Admiral mentioned over
the past few weeks we've been working
with each state to set a target for
their testing goal for me with over the
series of a couple of different calls
we've aligned on what those goals are
and as the Admiral mentioned and the
president mentioned they add up to over
twelve point nine million tests in the
month of May for every state this is
greater than two percent of their
population in the entire state being
tested in May and for many states it's a
much higher number than that when you
compare this as the president mentioned
to South Korea South Korea is actually
below that 2% not for a month but for
their total test to date since the start
of the year and so our states have come
back okay slightly ambitious goals that
we're excited to support them in meaning
if you go to the next slide as I talked
about last time in the press briefing
there are really three parts to making
sure that a test can happen the first
part is the specimen collection supplies
the second part is the machines and the
third part are the lab supplies that the
machines need to run and what we've been
working to do is to make sure that each
state has all three of those parts to be
able to conduct a number of tests the
first part is the specimen collection
supplies the commercial market today is
providing a large number of these
supplies are ready to States and are
ready to hospitals but we wanted to
ensure that every state had more than
what they needed to be able to conduct a
number of tests they're aiming in May so
what we've done is we've purchased
enough tests to support the state
testing goals for May and June so we
will be sending more than twelve point
nine million swabs and over ten million
media to the States over the course of
May and a similar a greater number over
the course of June in addition we have
several million in reserve so if states
are able to exceed their goal in the
third and fourth week of May we can
provide them even more slobs and
transport media and again this is in
addition to what's already available in
the commercial market if you go to the
next slide there are large numbers have
been talked about many times a large
number of testing machines across the
country over 5,000
different machines that can conduct
these tests the key part is making sure
that the machines and that the labs have
enough supplies to run the machines
there will be in the month of May
commercially produced over 25 million
test kits which is either the PCR and
extraction kits or the cottages to be
able to support tests and in their
effort states in their testing effort
and what we've been working to do with
each state is understand their total
goal and each of the manufacturers has
been a great partner with us and told us
how many tests they're shipping to each
lab in each state over the course of May
and what we know is that in the
aggregate the number of tests gives the
state is getting is greater than their
testing goal for the month of May in
addition to what the states have already
purchased there's over 7 million
additional tests that remain unpurchased
the majority of those from thermo Fisher
which is the most common machine in the
country so we feel very confident the
states will not only have the specimen
collection supplies and the machines but
also the extraction kits and the
reagents they need to be able to hit or
potentially exceed their testing goals
and if you go to the last slide the last
piece of the puzzle is making sure that
Americans have access to these tests
healthcare providers hospitals primary
care physicians are already providing
these tests today and we for the past
six or seven weeks have been partnered
with the retailers who have massively
been ramping up their effort today there
are over 240 retail sites we've been
working with the retailers to make sure
that they're specifically targeting
low-income and other vulnerable
communities across the country and we're
talking with them about potentially
opening more than another thousand
additional sites over the next month or
two
so we hope that we've put together the
right pieces of the puzzle having access
points for patients and Americans across
the country having the specimen
collection supplies needed to take the
test
having the machines and then also having
the lab testing supplies with the
machines so thank you very much all
important stuff all good stuff if it
happens and all happening way too late
ok please John go ahead
you can hear me we had a situation here
at the White House on Friday where a
member of the vice president's staff
tested positive for corona virus which
is now caused three of the top US
officials involved in the corona virus
response to self isolate two-part
question where did the system break down
to allow that to happen and where what
would you say to another is to look at
the experience here at the White House
and say are we ready for this I don't
think the system broke down at all and
one person tested positive surprisingly
because the previous day tested negative
right at some point you get the light
worried contact relative contact who I
believe they've all tested totally
negative but they are going to for a
period of time self isolate so that's
not totally negative
it can happen it's the hidden enemy
remember that it's the hidden enemy and
so things happen but the three tested
negative the one who tested positive
will be fine oh well I think you know we
have a lot of people at the White House
and we had one basically we had one
person three we had a lot of people that
work here this building is shocking if
you looked at the numbers and it's also
tremendous numbers of people coming in
normally you wouldn't do that
but because we're running a country we
want to keep our country running so we
have a lot of people coming in and out
many of those people most of those
people are tested depending on what
portion of the oval office area they're
going in everybody coming into the
president's office gets tested and I
felt no vulnerability whatsoever Jen but
the two people as I said and three
people are they have been tested and
it's negative and they'll be probably
out of quarantine very quickly well this
guy doesn't know any good if I can
follow up on that your staff your senior
staff is you just referenced is able to
get tested every day
when will it be that Americans across
the country will be able to get tested
every day as they can work very soon I
mean really very soon it's an
interesting question because normally
you would have said that you are not
tested and you would have been you know
knocking us but not getting tested so if
we get tested it's a problem and if we
don't get tested that's a complete
distort I like the way your question was
phrased better this way because it is a
positive we are tested we have great
capability you look at all of these
machines here their machines is that the
best anywhere in the world no place in
the world has this kind of equipment
other countries are calling
sophisticated countries and they're
calling lots of countries and we're
trying to make as much as we can
available them because there's nothing
like what we've been able to do in a
literally a couple of months what
they've been able to do the private
sector what they how they got it done
this is a five to fifteen minute test as
an example the Abbott Laboratories to
notice Trump's point think the test
question is when is people when is
everyone gonna be able to get tested
every day this is things that didn't
even exist a short while ago so we do
have a great testing capability at the
White House we're doing it and I think
generally speaking we had a call with
the governor's the other day generally
speaking they loved it without exception
they were all extremely happy with
what's going on with respect to their
testing what should people be told to go
back to work until they have that
assurance that they and their co-workers
are able to get which we're still not
there we're leaving that up to the
governors as you know and if we see
something wrong we'll call him out and
we'll stop it and it'll be there we are
leaving it up to the governor's some are
being not aggressive enough in my
opinion and some are being a little bit
aggressive but they're being very
careful and the people of the country
they've learned a lot over the last two
months they've learned about social
distancing and washing your hands and
other things that we've all learned and
talked about they've learned about I see
everybody just about everybody has a
face mask on you learned about face
masks the good and the bad by the way
it's not a one-sided thing believe it or
not but our country has learned our
country has been in the bad of the faith
and you see the numbers they're dropping
very substantially
numbers are dropping around our country
very very substantially so we leave that
John up to the governors and I think
they're making a lot of good decisions
we've had as I said a great relationship
with governor's Democrat and Republican
and I think overall they're making very
good decisions nobody in this group all
the ones behind the rope that's
interesting please you said in your
comments earlier we have met the moment
we have prevailed to you sir is the
mission accomplished even with one point
no we've prevailed on testing is what
I'm referring to that was with regard to
testing oh you never prevail when you
have 90,000 people a hundred thousand
people when you have 80,000 people as of
today when you have this the kind of
death you're talking about when you have
potentially millions of people
throughout the world that are dying
that's not prevail what I'm talking
about is we have a great testing
capacity now it's getting even better
there's nobody close to us in the world
and we certainly have done a great job
on testing and testing is a big is a
very big important function by the way
some people consider it more important
than others to be honest with you but
testing certainly is a very important
function and we have prevailed we have
the best equipment anywhere in the world
like some people consider testing more
important than others okay what people
for what like it's a meaningless thing
to throw in there the old technology
related to vaccine research is this
something you're concerned about what
can you say so what else is new with
China what else is doing tell me I'm not
happy with China they should have
stopped us at the source they could have
stopped it right at the source so now
you're telling me they're hacking so I
just say this Steve what else is new
well once you get very closely yeah if I
could follow up sir the South China
Morning Post the Beijing newspaper says
that China would like to reopen
negotiations on the trade deal to make
the terms more favorable to them
is this something you'd be interested in
doing no not at all hey there's a deal
that I had heard that - they'd like to
reopen the trade talk to make it a
better deal for them China's been taking
advantage of the United States for many
many years for decades because we had
people at this position right here where
I'm standing sitting right in that
office the Oval Office that allowed that
to happen right not interested in that
let's see if they live up to the deal
that they signed okay please go ahead
mr. president what are your thoughts
about a second round of direct payments
to Americans that's included in the the
House Democratic bill
well people I want to see a payroll tax
cut I want to see various things that we
want I want the workers to be taken care
of but we are talking about that we're
negotiating with the Democrats we'll see
what happens but as I said it's a
transition and it's a this is really
going to be in my opinion we'll see but
I think it's going to be something
that's going to be very special it's a
transition to greatness and greatness is
next year right from the beginning I
think we're going to do fantastically
well I view the third quarter as I said
as a transition quarter it could be
pretty good but it opens on toward the
end of the fourth quarter you're going
to see some numbers that are going to be
tremendous I think and next year you're
gonna have potentially the kind of
numbers that you saw before and maybe
even better because there is that
pent-up demand that is you know a lot of
people wanted to do things they were
ready to do things and they've had to
hold back because of the virus so I
think you're gonna have with that pent
up demand a phenomenal year next year
unless somebody messes it up by coming
along and raising taxes doubling
tripling quadrupling your taxes like a
certain party namely the Democrats want
to do people they'll mess it all up you
know we had the greatest in the world I
presided this administration presided
over it it got great for a reason and
we'll do it
and we'll do it again very quickly and
very easily I see that happening
yes ma'am please Thank You mr. president
almost everyone as you noted in the Rose
Garden is wearing a mask today why
haven't you required everyone at the
White House to wear masks before now
well if there are certain distance from
me or there are certain distance from
each other they do in the case of me I'm
not I'm not close to anybody I'd like to
be close to these two gentlemen they're
hard-working great men but they just
said frankly let's keep it this way so
there's a lot of my ports about Trump
thinks it'll hurt his re-election to be
seen wearing a mask and he thinks he'll
look dumb that's the truth but one of
them from what I see these are White
House staffers they're White House
representatives they're White House
executives and everybody has a mask on
we've had just about everybody I've seen
today has worn a mask yeah are you the
one who required that sir yeah I did I
did I required can you give us some
figures on what you're changing you got
to cover your thing win will that be a
true statement exactly and how exactly
are you going to accomplish that what's
a true statement already we have more
testing than any country in the world by
far but I'll let Admiral go into a
little bit of the future when you look
at the testing numbers that we worked
with collaboratively with with the state
leadership it's not just with the
governor but the state health officers
the state epidemiologist the public
health labs
it's really a combination of testing
those who need something for diagnosis
diagnostic testing tracing so testing
those who have been around the people
with a diagnosis but the largest
fraction of that is really moving into
surveillance that is testing those who
are asymptomatic and when you do the
numbers this amount of testing on a
state to state basis really is in the
range that we need to accomplish all of
that certainly within the range that we
need so it really encompasses those
three things the other thing I would say
is particularly as we move into the
summer there are surveillance mechanisms
and I talked about them before like a
weather radar and just think about that
weather radar on the influenza-like
illness Network which is at about 75% of
hot of health care institutions and
syndromic surveillance so if we see a
blip on that weather radar combined with
CDC personnel in every single state and
with contact tracers we really run to
the fire right and that's when you
detect you trace and you shut off that
outbreak right when it starts seems to
be a double standard here mister
president where members of your own
staff can get tests frequently when they
need it but ordinary Americans cannot so
when will the rest of America have the
same access that members of your own
White House he's not gonna they keep
asking you know what if we didn't get
the tests if we did no tests in the
White House should be up complaining why
aren't you getting tests for the White
House see we can question if we didn't
get the test you'd be up I understand
you very well better than you understand
yourself and frankly if we didn't you'd
be up complaining about the fact that we
didn't have the test set now that we're
doing so well on tests and so quick and
so fast
five minutes etc and so accurate can you
be complaining that we're getting too
many tests so you can't win go ahead
Phil what an idiot yeah it's the
president many Americans want to return
to their normal lives but they're afraid
to do so how can you ensure Americans
that it's safe to go to their own
workplaces when the most secure
workplace in the country the White House
cannot contain the spread of the corona
virus it's infected some of your own
staff well when you say some so we have
a person and the person got something
happened right after a test was done
three other people something I met that
person came into relative contact for a
little contact and their self
quarantining that is not exactly not
controlling it we I think we've
controlled it very well we have hundreds
and hundreds of people a day pouring
into the White House it's a mass of
people office complex including the very
large building right behind us that you
know so well so I think we're really
doing a very good job in
in watching it and I think it's very
well contained actually and part of the
reason it is because of all the tests
were able to give but it was one person
and the other people were only people
there quarantine do you understand this
Phil they're quarantined for a specific
reason the reason is they were in the
general proximity of the one person and
the one person I believe will be fine in
a very short period of time hasn't vice
president Pence followed the CDC
guidelines of self isolation and and
other people who might have been exposed
well that I'm gonna have to ask that he
will give you that information whatever
he is proceeding and doing he will give
you that information I'll make sure that
they completely cryptic mr. president up
until now it's thought that the most
vulnerable people were those above the
age of 60 or 70 or 80 and the children
were pretty much I don't want to say
immune from this but weren't affected by
it but all day long in the news today we
have been hearing and seeing this
terrible syndrome yeah and some 85
children have now three of them have
died what is the task force talking
about in terms of that and and what
could be done about you know we're
seeing that all over the world now with
young children very very tiny percentage
but it's still it's the swelling and the
skin rash and we're looking at that very
closely John it's a phenomena that's
just been brought to everyone's
attention couple nights ago and when you
may have something to say about that so
thank you for pointing that out and
again I've said many times I'm a
pediatrician and a pediatric ICU doctor
this syndrome which we call or similar
to Kawasaki syndrome it has been seen in
a novel coronavirus before and it's
associated with illnesses so we have a
very strong activation on this we do no
treatments for this but the CDC is act
is interacting actively with the
pediatric intensive care unit network to
create case definitions and to
understand how this is going and if
their predispositions the National Heart
Lung and Blood Institute I spoke to dr.
Gary Gibbons who directs that who is
advancing many research projects based
on that the asper the assistant
secretary for preparedness and
sponsz has a team out in several areas
looking at if there are any special
treatments we know what the basic
treatment is but this is a little bit
different than we normally see so there
really is an activation among all the
branches within HHS working with
networks at children's hospitals and ICU
nets it is a small percentage but it is
quite frightening and this reflects the
fact that this virus affects the
vasculature we see clotting we see
strokes and this is a vasculature
phenomena of inflammation we see in
children with this newly emerging
syndrome now among young children what
do you say to parents who would like to
get their children back to school but
are now we're looking at this and
potentially afraid to do that well again
it's a tiny percentage but you're right
so we're looking into it very strongly
and the Admiral as he said in three
month you're suffering about now before
this happened but it is a very very
small percentage and people recover from
that the children recover from that
right yes sir most do recover from this
but it is a it is a serious and it can
be a fatal condition oh people can die
we do want to make sure that parents
understand that high fevers red rashes
particularly in your child you may need
to contact your health care provider
there are treatments for this they work
very effectively if if gotten early at
least for the vast majority of the cases
we're studying that very closely
Wright's been on the radar for weeks
actually because we've seen this for
quite a while but Amazon small with very
rare but we're we're looking at it very
closely it's very important to us I
think one of the things were most proud
of is this just came out deaths per
100,000 people death so deaths per
100,000 people Germany and the United
States are at the lowest rung of that
ladder meaning low is a positive not a
negative Germany of the United States
are the two best in deaths per 100,000
people as you all can see what Sharon
Namie that's perhaps the most important
number there is please go in the back
please thank you not looking good I'm
not a brie Payson won on the coronavirus
the first on the coronavirus to present
the vice president is said to be in some
sort of self isolating keeping his
difference from people what do you say
to Americans who say how can you how can
you keep me safe how can you reopen the
government if even the vice president is
self isolating and why hasn't testing
come to the point where every mayor
American who wants a test can get a test
well the vice president first of all has
been tested and he's negative and it was
tested yesterday tested today and he's
negative
he's a very good shape and I think that
that's going to be fine as far as
Americans getting a test they should all
be able to get a test right now if they
should be able to get a test that's the
problem with a question like that we go
through a whole how does he not get it
he says maybe we'll do 12 million tests
in May and everyone can get a test well
of course that's not true there's 331
million people here how can you say if
we do everything perfectly 12 million
will get tested in May and everyone can
get a test doesn't make sense the Attar
think it's horrible and it's certainly
being looked at by many people I'm
speaking of many people about it
he looked I saw the picture of him in
his tuxedo it was so beautiful I bet he
looks like a wonderful young guy would
have been a wonderful I mean just a
wonderful guy I think it's a horrible
thing I think it's a horrible thing now
with that being said as you know they're
studying the case very carefully they're
interviewing everybody involved and
we'll see what happens to me it's a very
sad thing I spoke to a number of people
that are very much involved in it I've
been following that one very closely it
breaks your heart to watch it it breaks
your heart
and certainly the video was a was a
terrible looking video to me but you
have a lot of people looking at it and
hopefully an answer is going to be
arrived at very quickly but it's
something that is heartbreaking
question about the case if I could ask
it the specific question I have is you
said that there possibly are things that
happen that that that were not recorded
on the tape could you expound on what
you mean by that and your thoughts John
well I saw the tape and when they moved
left
I don't believe when they moved left
outside of the tape nobody saw what was
going on nobody saw it's an empty spot
on the tape I guess now do they have
additional tapes I hope but I will say
that it's something that based on what I
saw does it look good somebody that I
have a lot of respect for is Senator
Scott of South Carolina you know who I'm
talking about he's a great gentleman
he's a great senator is a great
gentleman Tim Scott and I called him two
days ago I said Tim what do you think
tell me what do you think he calls Tim
Scott is black this happened in Georgia
he's like hey I know I know a black guy
he's the senator from South Carolina let
me call him and see what he thinks
because he happens to be black questions
one on testing and one on democratic
states entreated about first the money
for this new testing support today comes
from the Care Act cares Act which you
signed into law 42 days ago did your
delay and embracing widespread testing
have anything to do with the desire to
suppress the official number of US cases
and deaths as you try to reopen the
country no we just wanted to make sure
that we had the proper machinery
apparatus and everything else out there
before people started wasting money so
method of saving money we want to make
sure we had even things like this plus
they have machines that are far more
complex than this they have massive
machines at some of the laboratories
that can do millions of tests we want to
make sure everything was in place okay
go ahead
earlier today you tweeted that Democrats
are moving slowly for political purposes
why do you believe that their motive is
politics rather than Public Safety and
how do you respond to criticism that
you're also motivated by politics to try
to grow the economy ahead of the
election well I think that if you look
at Pennsylvania's an example that's if
you look at various other states um I
won't get into them the people want to
go back
the numbers are getting to a point where
they can and it just seems to be no
effort on certain the idea that Trump
could actually answer a question with
multiple clauses within it I mean it's
just the Trump can't do it our country
open I want our country open too I want
it open safely but I want it open don't
forget people are dying the other route
you can go with the enclosed route
everything's closed up you're in your
house you're not allowed to move people
are dying with that too you look at drug
addiction you look at suicides you look
at some of the things that are taking
place people are dying that way too you
could make the case it's in even greater
numbers so it's a it's a situation that
some people and I've noticed that some
states could be moving more quickly and
also at the same time safety look safety
is paramount but people are dying in the
lockdown position too and everybody
understands that they're just starting
to find out yeah and look at what's
going on my drugs and look at what's
happening with suicides you know please
please go ahead
so Americans have been self-quarantine
for several months now social distancing
yet we're still seeing about 20,000 new
cases a day one to two thousand deaths
is there anything else the
administration is planning to do to get
these new cases under control because we
seem to be on a plateau well excuse me
there 20,000 the numbers are way down
from what they were two weeks ago I mean
the numbers are really coming down and
very substantially this weekend was one
of the lowest we've had this is you know
the numbers are coming down very rapidly
all throughout the country by the way
there may be one exception but all
throughout the anybody the rivers are
coming down rapidly I think you see that
Admiral 130,000 cases that go through
August
well the models haven't been exactly
accurate these are models done by a lot
of think tanks a lot of universities you
look at some of the models they've been
way up a few of the models have been
accurate but as far as the models are
concerned if you go by the model we were
going to lose 2.2 million people if he
didn't cuz we took we mitigated we did
things that we're very tough for our
country to do frankly we had to turn off
our whole magnificent economy we had to
turn down the whole country we're at the
lowest of all of the models I mean if
you look at I guess that 120 100 to 100
so it's not true Trump was talking about
60 K were at 80 K he's talking about a
hundred K the model says 135 K we're not
at the lowest he's lying he's lying to
you uncontrollably and to lose for this
is too many people it's a disgrace what
happened but if you look at the models
we're at alone at the lowest of those
projections but the models are not
models done necessarily by the White
House they're models done by many people
all over the world and if you take the
most respected of those people many of
those models are wrong I mean they've
been wrong as far as the u.s. is
concerned because those numbers are
nowhere near what was projected
potentially
of what the death toll is gonna look
like by the summer by this you know what
I don't want to think about it even I
know that we're doing we're doing a good
job reacted very early that's it reacted
extremely early in keeping China out of
our country in banning young people from
China coming in other than our citizens
we obviously had to taken they were
quarantined or watch carefully they were
tested they will watch very carefully
but we had about 40,000 people coming in
from China from Asia and we had to
obviously take the people can you
imagine okay I said you're a US citizen
we're not going to take you that doesn't
work so but they were very carefully I
was with Ron disentis he said they put
literally put the people they came in
from China in quarantine for a
substantial period of time no that was a
big decision I think we saved hundreds
of thousands of lives by acting very
early and when I did this I think the
Admiral can say it everybody was against
my doing it everybody everybody was the
professionals the doctors I was pretty
much by myself on that one and it was a
lucky thing we did it because we saved
hundreds of thousands of lives yeah play
is good
Thank You mr. president earlier today
the vice president urged governor's to
have all their nursing home residents
tested why not just mandate that why not
require that have you considered that
well I would certainly consider that I
will mandate it if you'd like I would I
think it's important to do like I said
some of the governor's were very lacks
with respect to nursing homes it was
obvious right from the beginning the
state of Washington where 26 or 28
people died very early on and I would
have said nursing homes and I did say
nursing homes that's what they should
now some of the states many of the
states are doing that but I think all of
the states should be they have the
capacity to do what they should be doing
nursing home that is a real
vulnerability the two staffers that were
announced last week as testing positive
are you aware of any additional White
House staff no not at all
I'm only aware of people that saw them
were tested the tests were negative and
they're quarantining anyway so please go
ahead I wanted to ask are you now or are
you considering separating some more
with Vice President Prince as a
precautionary measure well first of all
the job he's done on task force the job
he's done frankly on the vice president
of the United States standing and he's a
warrior too just like doctors and nurses
I mean he is working so hard and he's
coming into contact with a lot of people
but again he tested negative so we have
to understand that but he comes into
contact with a lot of people it's
something probably during this
quarantine period we'll probably talk
about I have not seen him since then but
I would say that he will he and I will
be talking about that yeah we could talk
on the phone
the president just said that doctor foul
Qi dr. Han I have tested negative then
why do they need to be isolated is there
some concern that they could be
spreading the virus in some ways their
concern about the testing why do they
need right I mean if thousands this is
though there are negative why are they
doing different so happy you brought
that up because it underlies a lot of
the questions here if you test negative
just at that one point that just means
you have tested negative for that point
in time we know that the incubation
period for this virus can be many days
so the CDC guidelines really says that
if you're in close contact just testing
negative on that one day doesn't mean
you won't be positive later on so the
prudent and the recommended thing to do
is to self isolate yourself for the
entire period of incubation and really
then some so that's what they're doing
it's a precautionary manner because they
were naked and why not pet we all hope
that they remain negative but if they
turn positive in a day or two or became
symptomatic that's still possible even
with a negative test okay
mr. president and one of your mother's
day tweets you appear to accuse
president Obama of the biggest political
crime in American history where are they
burger works
what crime exactly are you accusing
President Obama of committing and do you
believe the Justice Department should
prosecute him Obama game it's been going
on for a long time it's been going on
from before I even got elected and it's
a disgrace that it happened right if you
look at what's going on if you look at
now all of this information that's being
released where's that in the end from
what I understand that's only the
beginning some terrible things happened
and it should never be allowed to happen
in our country with the crime and you'll
be seeing what's going on over the next
over the coming week and I wish you'd
write honestly about it but
unfortunately you choose not to do so
yeah John please what is the crime
exactly thank you think you know what
the crime is the crime is very obvious
to everybody what you have to do is read
the newspapers except you know
what is the crime I can just get a
clarification on the on the testing
we've seen clearly that the numbers of
tests of going up there been some
advancements in testing but you've said
twice here today that every American who
wants a test can get a test yes that's
not the case 1.9 million tests per day
is far short of every American that
wants a test to be able to I'm gonna
have the advil but I will say just from
listening and hearing like you do we all
do not everybody should get a test
because they have to have certain thumbs
and they're gonna know when they're not
so here's the deal in May we're gonna
test that most 12 million people and
everyone can get a test even though 12
million is less than 331 million but not
everybody should get a test anyway so
then it doesn't even really matter how
many tests we have now in America
anybody who needs a test can get a test
in America with the numbers we have if
you are symptomatic with a respiratory
that is an indication for a test and you
can get a test if you need to be contact
traced you can get a test and we hope
and not hope we are starting to have a
symptomatic surveillance which is very
important again that's over three
million tests per week that is
sufficient for everyone who needs a test
symptomatic contact tracing at against
or on to our best projections the ace
matic only some kind of surveillance we
need to get that and that that's the way
it is and remember um I I work at HHS
I work there every day I don't get
tested every day I get monitored for my
symptoms am i febrile do I have any
other symptoms I wear a mask when I go
in that's a safe work environment for
the environment we have if I became
symptomatic I would get a test and if it
were positive I would isolate and
there'd be contact tracing to stop that
just the way it was done here if I'm not
symptomatic I do the precautions as
everyone is recommended in phase one and
that's the essence of safe to safely
opening America and John the numbers are
coming way down and they're coming down
rapidly and that's a beautiful thing to
see that's not that's pretty much
universally all across the country
they're coming down very rapid it's
acutely not true very important please
go ahead if so so Americans who are
going back to work shouldn't expect and
shouldn't need shouldn't want to have
the same thing that people coming to
work here at the White House have which
is the ability to get tested regularly
regardless of symptoms so let me clarify
as well yeah people who come into close
contact with the president get tested on
a regular basis oh if I were not in
close contact with the president
specifically I would not get tested like
most people here do not get tested
that's a very specific circumstance when
I work at HHS I go at HHS I don't get
tested I do the exact thing that we
asked Americans to do to monitor your
symptoms if you were symptomatic self
isolate get tested Ward's what are our
community-based testing sites at your
hospitals they're even at-home testing
now that has been authorized and and to
cooperate that if you need to be contact
traced be contact trace and cooperate
with your local public health but not
everybody who walks in here gets tested
every time they do if you're symptomatic
here at HHS at a meatpacking plant at a
school you need to get tested and the
meatpacking plants now we're doing very
well there's great testing around those
plants and we're finding out who had the
problem they're being quarantined and
the Meatpacking is moving along very
nicely but they were they were trouble
spots they were hot zones definitely
please and you know one thing I think
it's very important that John just to
finish we have now and nobody says it
they just don't want to write it by far
more tests than any other country the
quality of our test is the best anywhere
in the world that's very important to
say please go ahead to make sure I
understand the White House this position
are you saying that right now you feel
there is enough testing how to quit
testing across the United States or do
you feel that it needs to be ramped up
and by how much if so does it need to be
ramped up we've been I think we've been
clear all along that we believe in the
data indicate we have enough testing to
do the phase one gradually we reopening
that has been supported in the in the
president's plan and the task force plan
and it has to be a phased reopening
nobody's saying turn the light switch on
and everyone go because then it would be
really impossible to control the spread
of the spread of the virus you know
there are many many models out there the
Rockefeller Foundation published as
their recommendations of about three
million tests per week that's exactly
what we're doing if you look at our
agent based models it's far below that
if you take the Safra Center at Harvard
and correct their Mis assumptions like
on the sensitivity of the test the
mitigation processes and how many people
get hospitalized you get about that
number now I am NOT going to come here
and say we can absolutely swear it's
God's truth that this is the number we
need but we know we have enough to open
and we're gonna be very careful with our
ili net with our surveillance programs
and what the day to come in to inform us
even further as we grow and learn a
little bit
most days I don't come to the White
House to work I either go to FEMA or I
go to HHS and let me just talk you
through what the protocols are there
because I would never get tested if I
wasn't coming to the White House so
every day when we come in we get our
temperature taken and we get asked
questions about if we have symptoms if
you don't then you enter the workplace
and then there's hand sanitizer all over
the place in rooms that are made for
conference for
they put pieces of paper that say don't
sit and essentially every other every
third seat to separate people and so
there's a lot of precautions that we're
taking in the federal government that
are separate from testing and those are
the precautions that the agency is that
Admiral Gerar and I are working at every
day are using the same stuff over and
over again people want to get tested
they get tested and there's we have the
greatest capacity in the world
well clearly not want to get tested they
get tested but not true for the most
part they shouldn't want to get tested
there's no reason they feel good they
don't have sniffles they don't have sore
throats they don't have any problem if
they do feel there's something happening
they have the absolute easy in fact
Rhonda Santos of Florida the governor's
doing a fantastic job in Florida he said
he's got a little bit of the opposite
problem he's got so much testing that
people sit around and wait for people to
come in that they have far a great over
capacity for testing and there are
numerous numbers that's by the way a
good problem not a bad problem okay yeah
go ahead please many times that the u.s.
is doing far better than any other
country when it comes to testing yes why
does that matter
why is this a global competition to you
if everyday Americans are still losing
their lives and we're still seeing more
cases every day well they're losing
their lives everywhere in the world
nasty question and maybe that's a
question you should ask China
don't ask me yes China that question
okay when you ask them that question
she's gonna get arrogant or unusual
answer yes because White House press
corps can you imagine why are you saying
that to me specifically I'm told you I'm
not saying it specifically to anybody
I'm saying it to anybody that would ask
please go ahead okay next next place
that must have been Caitlyn Collins I
did and you didn't respond and now I'm
calling on the young lady in the back
please ladies and gentlemen thank you
very much appreciate it thank you very
much Wow
Trump Caitlyn
Collins just shut down a Trump press
briefing she just shut the well Fox has
already off of it
Katelyn Collins Trump ragequitting oh my
goodness can somebody please clip that
form I need a bunch oh my goodness so
let's see here I need a bunch of clips
from this I need the way Jia Jiang
question we need Kate if anybody can
Erin Roop are is probably gonna tweet
these so if somebody can send me them at
the the links to his tweets Kaitlyn
Collins ragequit moment and then what
was the other one there was one other
one that I wanted hold on a second Oh
what okay the Obama gate crime when
Trump was asked what crime was committed
and he said the crime is Obama gate if
somebody could do me the favor just
because I mean I'll do it obviously I
don't need your help producing the show
but it helps if you can monitor 80 are
you PA are Erin Roop ours Twitter he
almost always posts these and email me
those three clips it's wei jia Jiang's
question where Trump says why don't you
ask ina she says why are you telling me
to do and he's like no I'm not I'm not
Caitlyn Colin's forcing a ragequit and
then the Obama gate is the crimes thing
please get that stuff over to me because
I really really need that okay let me
thank the best way to support this
stream and every stream is when you get
a membership on my website info is there
let me thank some people Mary Erickson
signed up on my website John Kurokawa
has signed up on my website Harrison
sweet is new member number three today
Marcia Tyndale is new member number four
Kevin fountain your new member number
five also want to say thanks to Sarah
Baldwin whose new member number six at
join pakman.com Jean badger Ski pledged
on patreon but we're gonna count it all
so gage grits Minh is new member number
eight
Robert havens is number nine today
beautiful Andre Ruth is new member
number ten on my website also a big
THANK YOU to Madhuri single who is new
member number
then I I really do appreciate all of the
support from people who sign up we do
have this coupon code 20/20 now which
will save you 66 percent and everybody
will get a thank you let me quickly take
a look and see if Aaron has posted any
of those clips I just mentioned he's
usually pretty quick with this stuff
let's take a look so there's that one oh
here it is this was a beautiful moment
mr. president in one of your Mother's
Day tweets you appear to accuse
President Obama of the biggest political
crime in American history by far those
words what crime exactly are you
accusing President Obama of committing
and do you believe the Justice
Department should prosecute him Obama
game it's been going on for a long time
[Laughter]
what an idiot
okay I don't think he has the others he
oh he or he was asked what the death
toll is going to be he said I don't even
want to think about it okay so we we
these clips are clearly going to be
available to me for tomorrow's program
but what what a nightmare dystopian
situation I mean just completely
unbelievable a few super chats that have
come in dream hollows has open up
protests alone promised hundreds of
cases if not thousands Connor Brenner
says Schwab lightshow says Trump why
should I use facts when I can listen to
my feelings exactly is John snow on the
wall I don't really get that one John
Simon says where is the wall being built
right it could be between states for all
we know
Steve Latian says repeat repeat repeat
etc yeah that is the strategy that is
the strategy that they are employing
here a people watching on twitch I have
so many of you to thank for getting
those twitch subscriptions Adam Punk
I am Compu bear as well as Eric
Rothschild socialist who else shim Ron
Ron as well as grok 23 Sluman sup DNS
go smash and Genoa everybody just
signing up very very important stuff and
so appreciated alright I may be
streaming the fowey testimony tomorrow
we're trying to work out the schedule
not totally sure yet but certainly
certainly if there is another briefing I
will be here remember get my daily email
digest of the show for free by signing
up at david pakman.com we'll see
everybody tomorrow new clips publishing
on youtube for the rest of the night
you